everybody
[Music]
like most of the Beehive Jay-Z thinks
his wife Beyonce should have taken home
the 2023 Grammy for album of the year in
an interview with title conducted before
the award ceremony the rapper opens up
about his wife's previous album of the
Year losses for 2008's I Am Sasha Fierce
2013's Beyonce and 2016's lemonade
[Music]
and why he thought Renaissance deserved
the coveted award this year quote the
truth is we grew up wanting to be on the
Grammys and it was our goal we just want
them to get it right that's what we want
adding that he thinks the Grammys missed
the moment I just know that that my
passion and my love
is what motivates me as for why he
thinks Renaissance deserve to win album
of the Year Jay says look what it's done
to the culture look how the energy of
the world moved they played her whole
album in the club I don't know if I've
ever seen that we support each other
that's what we do Jay goes on to explain
that Bee's new music has inspired the
world when it just inspires creativity
that's an album that has to be album of
the Year very inspiring you know of
course Harry Styles ultimately took home
the album of the Year award for Harry's
house
I think like on nights like tonight it's
obviously so important for us to
remember that there is no such thing as
Best in Music
um I don't think any of us sit in the
studio thinking making decisions based
on what is going to get us one of these
but Queen B
her reasons to
thank you so much
I'm trying not to be too emotional and
I'm trying to just
receive this night the singer shared an
inside look at her post Grammy
celebration dancing with her hubby and
celebrating with her bestie Kelly
Rowland and her mom Tina Knowles Lawson
I'm as excited as everybody else she put
two years of love into this
many many nights all night working and
speaking of Tina she shared this clip to
Instagram Wednesday a sweet display of
support from an anonymous source writing
in the sky Beyonce you made music
history
[Music]
laughs